i've got to go to this email it came in
and it reminded me of a conversation i
had
at my house over the holidays and it
also reminds me of
conversations i have here at my work so
the email comes in from connor
how do i even get my head in the right
place to start
planning my will the thought of dying
scares me but i know this is important
so this comes into the dave ramsey
office and they were like hey we know a
guy that can answer that question
the thought of dying scares me but i
know it's important
so over the holidays i sat down and
talked to my dad
about the fact that he's gonna die and
he talked to me about his will
and my mom's will i talked to my mom we
had a big family discussion about it
hey mom you're going to die what would
you want your funeral to look like
and she's like whatever you all want and
i said no you have to tell us
don't put this on us please because then
we're going to fight about it i'm going
to want to have poison songs and pantera
songs and
my sister is going to want to like do it
the right way and all that kind of stuff
right
and we talked about it and it was half
smiling and half very serious but in our
house and again i'm blessed my dad is a
homicide detective we just talked about
death since i was a little kid and
that's probably why i had to see a
counselor but
it's gonna happen we did a big study uh
a few years ago and we came up with a
startling conclusion
a hundred percent of you listening to
this are gonna die someday
it will simply happen it's going to me
too
um there's this awesome guy out there
watching the show
him too james kelly zach i don't know
about kelly
kelly may be able to buck the system 100
james
and zach they're gonna die right you're
gonna die gonna die
i'm for sure gonna die it's part of it
right and i'll also say this not
everybody can talk about death oh
and then me and my wife part of our uh
annual retreat
we redid our wills we got on uh
a will thing here that we have here at
the ramsey office
uh will program mama bear wills and we
redid our wills together
and we talked about you're gonna die i'm
gonna die someone's gonna have to take
our kids someone's gonna have to and
we've filled in the blank who we want to
have the guitars who do we want to have
whatever and we went through that whole
thing
so i know that i'm blessed when it comes
to that conversation because i've talked
about death with enough people over the
years
to know that for most of you it's super
awkward
this is not an a a this
the fact that you're gonna die not
having a will that is not an optional
thing
we have to stop talking about not having
a will or i'll get to it
my friend john king he's my best friends
on planet earth he said it best the only
reason to not have a will
is if you hate your wife and kids the
only reason to not have a will is if you
hate your husband
and you want to make things you want to
make life awful for your children
if you are single the only reason to not
have a will
is you want to torture your parents and
your friends
it's just inexcusable and it's
now it's so cheap you can do it online
um it's just inexcusable
you have to do it so here's the thing
most of us go through life avoiding hard
conversations we
avoid him at work we avoid him with our
the person that we're in love with we
avoided with the person that we are
crushing on we avoid them with ourselves
this is an easy one because we're all
gonna die
right it's it's easy but not easy right
like oh lose weight just diet and
exercise cool
and that's a trillion dollar industry
right most people
deep down crave real hard conversations
they just don't know how to start them
so here's a couple of quick tips number
one plan it
make a plan if you are single call a
friend over
if you need to get a glass of wine or
two and some trashy food i'm giving you
permission to order a pizza one night
you're gonna have
rocket gas the next day but go for it um
invite them over and say okay i gotta do
a will i want you to do this with me
we're gonna put on some music we're
gonna laugh our way through it
if you are married or you're about to
get married
if you have kids you've got a
you've got an emotional a psychological
a spiritual whatever
all al obligation you want to say you've
got to do it
so plan the conversation tell your wife
tell your husband tell your fiance
next week on friday we're going to have
a date but we're going to talk about
we're going to do a will i'm not doing a
will but having a will does not make you
die quicker having a will doesn't make
death more
imminent there it
yeah it drives me crazy you got to get
on the same page right um you're going
to have to have conversations like hey
who's going to be the executor of our
will
who's going to take care of our kids
who's going to be the power of attorney
how long do you want to be on
a ventilator how long do you want to
fill in the blank you got to have those
questions right
so here's what i want you to do um the
ramsey folks here that i work with they
came up with this awesome thing
text legacy l-e-g-a
i'm not trying to sell you nothing this
is just i'm tired of people dying
without wills
i cannot tell you how many people i've
sat with
and looked them in the eye or held them
as they are shaking they're crying so
hard
and their husband or their wife is dead
in the next room
or it's being wheeled outside on a
gurney and they look me in the eyes with
a look
it is a very unique look and they say
the words
what am i supposed to do now
if you've never helped somebody try to
get
county funding because they don't have
any money
to bury their husband because the money
is
there was no will and so it's going to
be all tied up in a mess
you've got to do it you've got to got to
got to and if you're young and you're
listening to this
get a will get it i don't care how old
you are how not old you are
text legacy to 33789 you're going to get
a free how to talk about your legacy
guide
they're going to push you to mama bear
wills and
please do that please do that it is so
cheap it's so easy you will check it off
your heart and mind and that's all i'm
going to say about it